[Music]
this month tesla plans to release a
major upgrade to its driver assistance
software fsd beta
that upgrade is expected to extend
public access to a feature intended to
help vehicles navigate cities
despite its name fsd or full self
driving still doesn't make cars fully
autonomous and tesla instructs drivers
to remain alert with their hands on the
wheel tesla began selling a driver
assistance package that it calls full
self-driving capability
about five years ago and so this feature
that's expected to help drivers navigate
in
cities
is part of that package
this expands upon tesla's existing fsd
system of driver assistance tools that
were designed mainly for highways tesla
has taken an unusual approach to rolling
out access to this upgrade a small group
of users has been testing this city
driving feature for quite a while and
using it on public roads often
recording videos of those experiences
and posting them
okay wow
that was awesome that has helped to
draw up a lot of interest and also
invited scrutiny as well
tesla owners can buy full self driving
for ten thousand dollars or use it
through a subscription of up to 199
dollars a month but the wider public
hasn't been granted access to the city
driving tool yet tesla has been
preparing to release its city driving
tool beyond that small group of people
who have been testing the software
drivers have now been able to request
the feature but ceo elon musk said they
would only be granted access after
having their driving habits evaluated
tesla has said it's taking into
consideration a variety of factors
including things like hard braking or
aggressive turning and it's using those
inputs to come up with a safety score
that will be
used to prioritize who gets access tesla
plans to release this upgrade to drivers
progressively around a thousand a day
based on their safety score but it
remains unclear
what happens if you get caught in this
space where tesla doesn't think your
driving is good enough the tesla crushed
after slamming into an overturned semi a
bay area tesla driver was playing video
games at the time of a deadly crash
tesla's latest upgrade comes in the wake
of a series of crashes that have
heightened scrutiny of the company's
driver assistance software the new chair
of the national transportation safety
board has been critical of tesla's
driver assistance systems and
really specifically the language that
the company uses to describe its tools
but
the agency doesn't have regulatory
authority this really is a space that is
not tightly regulated in the u.s and so
automakers have
a wide degree of
latitude
[Music]
tesla's driver assistance software comes
in two bundles autopilot comes as a
standard system on new vehicles and
primarily assists highway driving
the second package is what tesla calls
its full self-driving capability which
is essentially an upgrade that adds more
features but is only available to
customers who buy the package
tesla drivers have identified a variety
of tricks to make autopilot believe they
are focused on the road even if they are
literally asleep at the wheel for years
tesla has faced criticism from some
lawmakers about its driver assistance
software you can take a water bottle
take an orange and put it right into the
steering wheel
and then that tricks
the system to believing that your hands
are on the wheel
last month the ntsb launched an
investigation into a fatal crash
involving a tesla vehicle in florida and
in august the national highway traffic
safety administration said it was
investigating tesla's autopilot system
but it's likely going to take quite a
while for that investigation to
play out or just in the early stages
in recent months even musk has expressed
mixed views about the full self-driving
system we need to make full cell driving
work
in order for it to be a compelling value
proposition otherwise people are
uh you know
kind of
depending on the future i mean right
like right now
is it does it make sense for somebody
did do fsd subscription i think it's
debatable
tesla did not respond to a request for
comment
[Music]